he spent the last two years clocking up
more air mass than just about anyone
else on the planet so let's hope he has
some trade deals to show for it when the
UK does finally leave the European Union
I caught up with dr. Liam Fox the
international trade secretary just
before he left the g20 trade ministers
meeting in Argentina and I started by
asking him when the first post brexit
trade deal will be starstruck well of
course the g20 trade ministers isn't
about bilateral negotiations and we
can't begin any negotiations on trade
agreements until we actually leave the
European Union itself in March next year
but I did take the advantage while I was
here to have some quiet bilaterals with
my opposite numbers from India from
Japan Australia from the United States
and from the European Commission to keep
our conversations going and I'm going
from here to Canada but the main point
of the g20 negotiations was to lay the
ground for the heads of government
leaders who will meet here in Argentina
at the end of the year and we were
dealing with some of those big trade
issues that are out there the present
time the trade dispute between China the
United States which is having wider
ramifications and of course the issue of
the WTO itself and whether we now need
substantial reform and if so how we get
it so it was a fairly busy agenda it's
interesting that you are talking about
some of the meetings you've been having
with your counterparts from places like
India it feels to me is if one thing
that we haven't been talking about
perhaps as much as we should join these
can brexit discussions is immigration
immigration likely to be a very big part
of any trade deals that you strike with
countries such as India China Argentina
they will be likely to much be demanding
some relaxation of visa requirements so
do you think it's time for the
government to drop its target to reduce
net migration to the tens of thousands
no because we're going to have a real
sea change in our ability to control
migration with the end of free movement
and of course it's been quite an issue
with countries that you very quickly
mentioned like India that we give free
movement for EU citizens coming in when
companies that invest in the UK may want
to bring some of their own people
from and I think that we need to look on
this issue of what we know the British
people think and from attitudinal
survey's we know that the British people
think that if you've got if you come to
Britain and you've got a job and you pay
your taxes and contribute to the wealth
of the country that's welcome but what
hasn't been welcomed is people are able
to come to the United Kingdom on spec
and be able to use our public services
like education and housing and health
without ever having contributed anything
to the country and I think that is what
lay behind the strong public movement
against the concept of the free movement
of people in the European Union now as
we end that it means that within the
targets that we've set from migration
were able to set a more level playing
field if you like for the talent that
may come from overseas so a lot of
countries see our exit from the European
Union as a real bonus from that point of
view in that it does create a more level
playing field for them so if they see it
as a bonus presumably because they think
that there will be more emigration
access for some of their citizens could
we be seeing an increase in migration
from non EU countries after brexit well
what they think is that within the
limits that we have set as a country
that they will have a better chance of
being able to get access to some of
those places so it's not about more
migration but it's about not having the
migration picture skewered towards EU
citizens whether or not they have the
talents that employers are looking for
so again global employers and those
investors in the United Kingdom which
have made the UK the world's third top
destination for inwards investment and
the top in Europe can see the benefits
that the ending of free movements might
bring to them and to the UK economy one
thing that is kind of puzzling me a
little bit and about the debate on
immigration is that we effectively
haven't heard much about what the
government sees as its post brexit
immigration policy particularly cause
considering for many people it was their
number one reason for voting to leave
the EU so I'm interested to know for you
is it a red line that the preferential
status if you like of EU citizens is
ended
well we have to end free movement we
have to end free movement to honor the
result of the referendum we voted to
have control of our borders we voted of
control of our laws they voted have
control of our money and so we need to
see that that free movement is brought
to an end I think it's from from the
points I've been making too it's very
clear that it has its advantages not
just in terms of stopping public
services being used by those who haven't
contributed but can be an extra tool in
the box when it comes to future trade
negotiations with other countries so
it's something that you're planning on
using then kind of offering kind of
relaxation of these requirements in
return for a good trader well one of the
things that that companies that invest
in the United Kingdom do as British
companies that invest overseas do is to
say we want the freedom of what's known
as intra company transfers the ability
to have their own people running their
own businesses where we're able to offer
that more because we're able to control
our immigration by not having free
movement again that's an extra tool that
we will have and that's welcomed by the
global investors that I've spoken to
from the United States to the Far East
and everything in between okay now last
month you said that there was a 60%
chance at the No Deal outcome so do you
think that a No Deal a brexit outcome is
more likely or less likely now I think
over the last few weeks we certainly
hear more had more reassuring noises
from the European Commission and some of
our European partners and I think as
they've understood that prison is
serious that if we don't get a good deal
we could end up with no deal I think
that they've taken the economic view
that we have to get a liberal and open
agreement on trade with Britain more
seriously and I think that the dial has
moved in that direction impossible to
say how much because we need to get
agreement of all our European partners
but from the ones that that I've been
talking to in some of my colleagues
we've certainly seen a more positive
view about the need to get that economic
agreement and as I've often said I mean
I've even said on this program before we
have a real choice to make both Britain
and the rest of the European Union about
whether this is
brexit that's about the bureaucrats and
political ideology on one hand or if
it's actually about the prosperity and
the jobs and the well-being of the
people of Europe on the other and I very
much hope it's the latter if it is about
the prosperity in the well-being of the
people in Europe and the UK as well then
some people have suggested that in order
to prevent anodal outcome we should
effectively extend article 15 delay
Brecht say what would you say to these
people who argue that I'd say no as I've
said before extending article 50 until
we've got an agreement is effectively
allowing the European Union to dictate
when Britain will leave the European
Union itself let the public have given
us an instruction in the referendum
there has to be a time set for our exit
that's the 29th of March next year and
we should honor that now you it feels to
me this if you were one of a shrinking
pool if you like if a brexit is that the
Prime Minister can rely on to go out
there and defend her checkers plan do
you sometimes look at the game that
other people are playing in your party
and some of the comments that they'd be
making people who voted leave like
yourself
Boris Johnson perhaps Jacob Riis Morgan
think that actually they're playing a
bit of a dangerous game by trashing
checkers in public well I don't think
it's a game at all because the stakes
are so high for the United Kingdom for
Europe and beyond and and one of the
things that I've been picking up here in
Argentina from other g20 ministers is
that if there are new impediments to
trade an investment as a result of any
EU agreement with Britain then there are
lots of other places for international
investors to put their money rather than
than Europe but I think that that if you
look at the issue in the round do we
want an agreement or do we not want an
agreement yes in my view we should get
an agreement do we want one that
maintains an open and liberal trading
relationship with the European Union
which although it might be a shrinking
proportion of our total trade is still
not nonetheless about 43% of our exports
of course we want to do that we want to
access that European market in a way
that will encourage British businesses
to trade with Europe and courage
European businesses to trade with
Britain
while at the same time not tying our
hands for some of those big global
opportunities that are out there in the
future that involves an element of
compromise and what the government has
put - the European Union in terms of the
checkers offer and let's remember it's
still only an offer
nothing has been agreed yet is a
reasonable way to maintain that European
trade without tying our hands too much
no we're awaiting as you know a full
response from the European Union to our
ideas and we think it's a as I say a
reasonable constructive way forward if
they don't like those ideas then they
will need to come back to Britain and
say what they think is a way to maintain
all those elements of trade and also to
not see any divisions between the United
Kingdom that would make for example a
border down the Irish Sea making
Northern Ireland different from any
other parts of the UK a number of
different considerations but I do detect
that there is a movement from the
European Union
towards getting a deal it's by no means
certain but I think that it's moving in
the right direction although no deal
remains a possibility for which we have
to prepare it's interesting to hear you
say that checkers is a reasonable offer
I mean after two years of trying to for
the government trying to come up with
something surely you'd hoped that they'd
come up with something that you'd be
able to really sell to people rather
than just saying that it's a reasonable
offer there's lots of chatter around the
future of tourism a Conservative MPs
openly discussing whether or not she's
going to have to go after sealing the
deal on brexit do you think that Therese
May will lead the Conservative Party
into the next election you know I've
been Parlin for 26 years I can't
remember very many times when there
wasn't chatter about who was going to
take over the leadership of the
Conservative Party so I tend to aim off
a little bit if you'll excuse me for
that I think the Prime Minister is doing
a great job in difficult circumstances
both domestically because of the lack of
majority in the House of Commons and in
the difficult task of this negotiation
with the European Union and I think that
supporting the Prime Minister now
is in our national interests and
certainly if she wants to continue on to
the next election she will have my
support and I think a British prime
minister that delivers a successful
brexit will have the support of the
British public